my name is Dan Carson I'm studying
physics here at MIT and my research is
into the effects of radiation damage on
revco high temperature super correctors
so Repco stands for rare earth barium
copper oxide and it's a type of
superconductor that we're looking at
here that might t to build the next
generation of fusion devices so nuclear
fusion is kind of like making a star on
earth it's replicating what the Sun and
other stars do to produce almost
limitless amounts of clean carbon free
energy and so here at MIT were actually
building a new device called spark and
spark will be the first fusion device to
actually produce more power than it
takes to run and spark we'll do this by
actually using magnets for the first
time made of this material called Reb Co
and rubber Co is a very very special
material so it can actually it's a
superconductor which means it can carry
incredibly high amounts of currents and
under specialized conditions so here we
actually have like a traditional copper
cable you would see in a traditional
fusion device and here we have a little
piece of Repco and under certain
conditions this little piece of Repco
can actually carry the same amount of
current as this big copper cable and
that is what enables us in spark and in
future such devices to actually produce
such large amounts of power and so my
research focus is on is emulating how
the neutrons produced in fusion
reactions will actually damage Repco and
impact its performance over time and so
very little is actually understood about
how replicas will be damaged by such
neutrons in my work is actually focused
on applying reactor relevant irradiation
conditions like low temperatures and
high fields to these Repco samples to
emulate and predict how such magnets
will perform over time in fusion devices
which will impact the viability of these
devices going forward